نحن في منطقه المواصي هذه المنطقه هي محاذ
للاشتباكات التي تدور بين قوات الاحتلال
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك التوغو
الاسرائيلي في محيط جامعه الاقصى جامعه
الاقصى نفسها تعرضت لعمليات قصف قامت بها
طائره الاحتلال وكذلك المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وارتقى عدد من الشهداء داخل
هذه الجامعه مواطنون استطاعوا ونجحوا خلال
هذا الصباح من الوصول الى جامعه الاقصى
وقاموا بانتشال جثمان احد الشهداء من
عائله ابو الحسين بعد يومين من ارتقاء هذا
الشهيد داخل باحات جامعه الاقصى قصه الشاب
يسكن عند مستشفى ناصر في مدينه خان يونس
قالوا لنا اتجهوا الى المواصي مكان امن
واحنا نازحين طبعا قنص اليهود اطلقت علي
اربع رصاصات فاصابت جسده وهذا المكان
الامن اللي قالونا روحوا عليه تمت تصفيه
عدد كبير من الناس النازحه من مستشفى ناصر
في خانيونس الى المواص تم استهدافهم من
الطائرات ومن الدبابات ومن قبل القناصات
وهيو الان شهيد وعدد شهدا ملقى على الارض
عند الجامعه ولا احد يستطيع الذهاب والجثث
يعني معظمها
بتتحلل حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل معلش يما راح راح لجوار ربك بدل
الاخ اخوه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله شاهد
يا مازالت صفحات كتاب الالم مفتوحه في
قطاع غزه بسبب الحرب الاسرائيليه والسؤال
يتواتر على السنه المواطنين متى ستنتهي
هذه الماساه لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو
عمر خان يونس